that are responsible for evaluating the
operations and the state of the federal
agencies
so that an incoming biden harris
administration is prepared to lead our
country on day one
uh next just to give you an update we
wanted to we will soon be launching a
new feature in the coming days on our
website
buildbackbetter.com that will encourage
the american people to apply for roles
in the biden harris administration
president-elect biden and vice
president-elect harris want the
administration an
administration that looks like america
and that means finding diverse
experienced talent from across the
country
next we have been hard at work for the
last few months of the transition
beginning to
identify experienced talent to fill the
nearly 4 000 political appointee roles
in government
just to give you a little bit of a frame
of reference the prior two
administrations
filled roughly 600 of those roles by day
100 and we're ahead of that schedule
finally there have been a number of
smart questions about the timeline for
cabinet announcements
for some historical context during the
2008 transition most of the obama biden
cabinet picks were announced in december
our priority right now is supporting the
president-elect and the vice
president-elect is that they seek to
build a diverse team of experts that can
confront the crises
facing the country on day one of a new
administration
so with that i think we'd love to open
it up to some questions
um osma khalid um has a question
yes hi uh i am meeting myself can you
all hear me
we can yes great thank you hey there um
so
yesterday the incoming chief of staff um
made some comments on msnbc suggesting
that
while the lack of cooperation from the
gsa
is not yet become a problem he
acknowledged it could be a problem
specifically as you look into vaccine
implementation in january and february
or on covet
so could you talk to us at all about
ways that you guys are thinking or
planning to mitigate some of that
given that he's already been thinking it
could be a problem absolutely and thanks
for the question asman for joining us as
well
so a couple things as as uh yo or
johannes but you can call him you
as i do um as he previewed um you know
there's been a lot of work going on
behind the scenes
um for months um including preparing uh
on for a number of policy issues
preparing memos and preparing documents
and decisions and things to tee up for
decision making by the president-elect
and the vice president-elect
and there's also been a lot of work on
personnel so those areas are ongoing and
i think that's what ron claim was
referring to
uh in part yesterday that we're charging
ahead with the transition
at the same time as he also touched on
um there are areas
where as much as uh president-elect
biden has been working on policy issues
from national security to health
for decades you need real-time
information to deal with crises of the
moment
so there are areas um so on the coveted
front like
access to ongoing work on distribution
plans uh vaccine development
that engagement directly with the
agencies would significantly help
our preparations um to govern and um
obviously at this pivotal time
and as we've seen thousands seen this
week thousands of americans have
uh lost their lives to covid um the
current president is
absent from that conversation and you
know it's imperative that
our team and our experts have that
access i i will also though
add the covet advisory board one of the
roles they can play
is providing um medical
public health expertise and and counsel
to the president-elect and the vice
president-elect as well as his team
on uh on all of these areas whether it's
um distribution or testing mechanisms
you know these are
talented experienced some of the
foremost experts in the country
their role was never going to be to
directly engage with federal
officials so they can continue providing
advice just as we had planned but
certainly we would prefer and i think
the american people would prefer if the
incoming
administration the incoming president
could have access to the real-time
current information and plans
[Music]
hey guys it's it's aim and jabbers i
don't know if you can hear me but
great great virtually thanks for doing
this appreciate it
um i have a question about the stimulus
between now
january 20th for the president-elect
does he support
a new stimulus bill moving forward in in
the sense of uh coveted relief
how big does he think that should be and
is he prepared to push lawmakers on
capitol hill
uh to move forward with that uh during
the next you know month or so
sure well amen as you know he's been the
president-elect for five days
and he had our six days sorry my math is
a lot there
um and he will he has been engaging with
and i expect he will continue to engage
with in the coming days
with leaders uh in congress um about the
stimulus
and about a range of priority issues uh
we don't have anything to
preview for you or uh outline for you at
this point
um but uh we would uh if you should
expect that he will continue to be
engaged in those discussions
and uh certainly wants to see the
american people receive
uh the relief they need
do you have a sense of um where that's
going to end up in terms of dollar
amounts i know you're saying you can't
preview it but
just give us a ballpark in terms of
scale of what he's thinking about
you know aim and we're not here to
preview the discussions that will happen
with
uh members of congress or to give you a
ballpark i wish we could
um but i would expect those
conversations will be ongoing uh in the
coming
coming days and weeks and as there's
more to share i'm sure we will
we will do our best to share it with you
okay thanks
janet's kristen can i ask a question hi
of course hi hope you're all well thanks
for doing this
a couple of questions uh
you had talked about and ron clayne had
talked about last night on msnbc the
fact that president-elect biden has had
conversations with republicans
can you tell us specifically who are
those republicans with whom he has
spoken and has he spoken leader
to leader mcconnell if not are there
plans for him to do so
so thank you kristin um and i i think as
as ron klain said last night
he has spoken with democrats and
republicans i will remind everyone that
all democrats and republicans also don't
live in washington d.c
so he'll also continue to talk with
democrats and republicans all around the
country including elected officials um
but we don't have anything more to um
read out for you in terms of his calls
um as you know and as i think ron claim
talked about a little bit last night
uh he and um speaker mcconnell i mean a
leader mcconnell sorry
have a um long-standing relationship
whenever they
do engage they won't have to play a lot
of catch-up they probably know each
other's family members names and
and all of that and i think uh
president-elect biden is certainly eager
to work with democrats but also
republicans
and certainly leader mcconnell on
putting the american people back to work
um bringing uh getting the pandemic
under control and all the various crises
that
the country faces but i have an
additional specific update for you on a
call
quick quick follow jen then just to be
clear so no
plans that you can preview that he's
preparing to
or has any um specific time to speak
with leader mcconnell and as a part of
that
um obviously james langford said he
would step in
uh if president-elect biden was not
receiving intelligence briefings by
today
we have our hill team working on that
but i would ask you have you been in
contact
um with lankford at all with as he's
made that
promise and what is your understanding
of what that would look like
well i don't want to speak for senator
lankford i certainly
bet he doesn't want me to speak for him
either so i will uh
i will send i'm sure your hill folks are
going to talk to him in his office but
you know i will say he's not the only
republican who has highlighted the
importance and the need for
president-elect biden to have access to
intelligence briefings and
while we well in earlier questions about
covid i would say
um intelligence briefings and access to
real-time threat assessments real-time
information about our engagements around
the world
um and the threats that we're facing uh
you know i think that
the fact that the incoming president and
his incoming national security team
doesn't have access to that
it's going to be surprising to anyone
that langford but also many other
republicans
a number of other republicans have
raised concerns about that so
i would certainly point you to him and
his office on what the next step is
there
um but but um you know we think that's
that's one of the biggest
um the biggest important reasons why
ascertainment is essential
also just you know because many of you
know this but in the 911 commission
report
um one of the things they talked about
was the impact on the delay
of um of the transition period on our
national security and so
i'm sure many republicans uh in the
senate have
seen and read that with interest um but
uh
hopefully we'll hear more and see more
coming out in the coming days thanks jen
thanks everyone hey john it's megan
castell
i had one quick follow-up on stimulus
first and just was
wondering what the thinking was or if
there were concerns that passing
anything before inauguration day might
limit the president-elect's chances to
pass his own package in early 2021
um especially if if something that does
pass isn't
as large as he might like to see sure
megan well i will just reiterate that
you know we're six days into the
transition here and uh as we noted and
as you've seen in readouts from the
transition and also from
leaders on the hill there have begun to
be there have been conversations started
that he's engaged
with we expect that will continue in the
coming weeks
uh but i don't have anything to uh
really update you on in that front today
okay and on one other note ron clayne
mentioned last night
sorry that reversing some of trump's
obamacare changes would happen on day
one
can you offer any specifics on what that
might include
uh that's you know there are a number of
ways number of steps that um
an incoming president or incoming
president biden can take
to um you know reinstate or re
support obama or the affordable care act
um
we can we can circle back with you megan
on the specifics on that um after the
call if that works for you
great thank you hi it's yamiche alcindor
with
pbs newshour thanks for taking my
question i have a two-part question you
you touched on it the 911 commission
saying that
um the delay imperiled there was the
country's response to 911
is there so is there how high of a
concern is it
for national security at this point um
or is there something else
obviously coveted on your mind when you
think about what the delay is actually
um
imperiling in that way and then the
second question i have is
what would it take to go to court i've
i've heard from some sources that
december 14th and and before being
certified seems like the time that it's
that it would be
ready that you would be ready to go to
court but i'm wondering if that if
that's actually
i'm the sense there sure let me take
this the second part first uh one i
think you'll be hearing more um
updates from the um campaign side um
today on the litigation around the
country and we'll certainly defer to
them on speaking to that
um but you know i will say that um well
no
presidential transition um or would take
any options off the table that's
certainly not our
preference um our priority uh would be
um or our our our preference i should
say
would be that the um gsa uh the
the ascertainment happens that the
letter is signed and
we all move forward in preparing to um
preparing president-elect joe biden and
vice president-elect
kamala harris to govern um we're not
interested in having a food fight with
the gsa administrator or anyone really
we just want to get access to
intelligence information to threat
assessments to
the ongoing work on kovid so that we can
prepare to govern bring the american
people to together and
get the pandemic under control um you
know and i think that
that's that that objective i think is uh
i think rings rings with a lot of people
around the country too and it's starting
to ring with some republicans so
i would say we did talk we've talked a
bit about it
it's been six days but with every day
that passes
um it becomes more concerning that our
national security team
and the president-elect and the vice
president-elect don't have access to
those threat assessments
intelligence briefings real-time
information about our engagements around
the world
um because um you know you don't know
what you don't know um
and in order to prepare to govern it's
important that they have access to that
information
and jen i would just uh add i think all
that
all that's right president-elect biden
has a wealth of experience spanning
decades as it relates to
national security and foreign policy
issues and he surrounded himself
with a team that is similarly seasoned
and experienced but exactly as jen said
each passing day lack of access to
current classified operations or back
channel conversations that are happening
really put the american people's
interest as it relates to their national
security at risk
yeah that's the issue he knows his way
around the situation room he knows
he doesn't need a briefing on uh you
know where to go to get things on a
national security team it's it's the
real time
threat assessment information
intelligence briefings that
um we would like to see him have access
to but i could do a
i quick wonder if you could also talk
through um
not it sounds like you're not back
channeling with agencies and it seems
like that
maybe it's because you don't want to put
them in a tough situation but could you
talk a bit about that
and the decision to to work with former
officials but not kind of informally
have conversations
so i'll i'll take that one um throughout
the course of the transition
we've been in regular contact with uh
federal career officials who are tasked
with
administering transitions who are
non-partisan
career experts on the on transitions
including at gsa
there have been regular meetings of
something called the agency transition
directors council which many of you are
familiar with
that is comprised of representatives
from the
various federal agencies who are tasked
with the nuts and bolts of executing on
a transition
and so we've been in regular contact
with those career officials
now in terms of the work of the agency
review teams
obviously pre-ascertainment they do not
have access to
officials inside of the federal
executive but
in order to move forward in this time
period before ascertainment
we plan for every scenario pre-election
and one of them is the unfortunate
situation we find ourselves in where
um despite the clear and convincing win
we have not been ascertained yet
and so the agency review teams are
embarking on a program of
working with people who are similarly
familiar with the federal executive
to make sure that we have a running
start into the period of time
post-ascertain and then most importantly
a running start into
day one of an administration if i could
follow up on that this is tara kopp with
mcclatchy
um does the upheaval at the pentagon
concern president-elect biden and the
transition team
and has any member of the transition
team been able to reach out to some of
the
senior uniform military officials at the
pentagon to get some of those wheels in
motion that you're talking about the
intelligence the the knowledge of what
they're dealing with at present time
you want me to start yeah great okay so
as
johannes just previewed i mean there is
until there's ascertainment um
there isn't going to be official
engagement between
um personnel members of our agency
review teams many of whom have served
for decades in national security
agencies
with current officials um so of course
it's of concern
to see the people it should be of
concern to anybody um because
there shouldn't be a politization of the
military
but i would just go back to something
johannes mentioned earlier and i think
you'll see more of this in
in the in the time between now and
thanksgiving is
you know president-elect biden has a
wealth of
not just experience but contacts people
he's worked with in the past
people who he can engage with to get
briefings have discussions
with in the national security field um
and he'll certainly be doing that and
while our agency review team can't be
engaging directly
with the agency uh many of them have
served
relatively recently and and also have an
understanding of
what the needs are and how we can uh
work together to
address the threats to the degree we
have the information we need and
obviously i've touched
just to follow up on that um has there
been any discussions
as to why you think he did you know
replace
esper replace a lot of the top officials
at the pentagon is there concern that
uh trump may make some sort of domestic
use of the military if he continues to
contest the election or that maybe it's
uh to deal with some sort of uh
foreign concern such as withdrawing
troops from afghanistan
you know i think from the transition
side our objective is to follow the lead
of president-elect biden which is to
encourage
calm and to reassure the american people
that not only is the outcome of the
election clear not only was there not
fraud as uh as officials from uh the dhs
from the from dhs put out a statement
saying just yesterday or this morning
it's all running together
um but you know part of his objective is
also rebuilding those institutions
and so um you know i i would say from
our perspective
um you know i can't get into the minds
none of us can on this end
of president trump or anyone around him
on the decisions they make
all we can do is project um how he would
govern
and how he and vice president
elect harris will govern uh which
certainly is in stark contrast in a
number of ways but one of them is
respect for the civil servants who have
served um the country many for decades
respect for the military
um and you know that's what people can
expect when they're inaugurated and
between now and then
his objective is to uh get advice where
he can
obviously we would like to have access
to real-time threat assessment and
real-time intelligence briefings
uh but also to tap into his wealth of uh
experiences wealth of contacts um who
uh on these issues so he can be as up to
speed as possible
hey guys alexis mcfamin with axios thank
you so much for doing this and happy
friday
um so just to be clear there are no
plans to like track these folks with
plans then rehire them
folks who are being fired by president
trump and then
separately i'm curious if there are
other agencies that you're worried about
based on public reporting and otherwise
that you're tracking in the coming
months and finally
will family members be barred from
serving in the white house or
administration in any official way
sure all great questions um let me take
the ones we can and
some of the pieces i it's hard to
preview uh on day six of the transition
um but i will say that um wait go back
to your first question
sorry i need a little bit more coffee
and i you asked a couple so
any plans to sort of track the folks who
are being fired by president trump
with eventual plans to rehire them
sure well look i i will say just as a
principle um
that rebuilding the institutions of
government that have been hollowed
by this administration um finding ways
to engage
uh with the civil servants the um the
career officials who have are frankly
the heart and soul of government and i
served in the state department for two
and a half years
those those agencies wouldn't function
without
the thousands of people who have served
for decades is a priority for
president-elect biden and vice
president-elect paris
exactly how that happens or which
personnel will be
brought back or asked to come back or
the process i don't have more to preview
i don't know johannes if there's
anything more from your end on that
particular
what i'd say there is um to jen's point
you know the state of the federal
executive is something that obviously we
we all have concerned about and what our
team has done is take a look agency by
agency
and from really from the bottoms up to
an assessment as to
what are the priority positions that
need to be filled within the 4000 that a
president
has the ability to fill in order to do
the job of building back better on day
one
in order to meet the demands of
president-elect and vice
president-elect's agenda
and in terms of thinking through the
actual personnel for those positions it
goes back to something we said at the
top we're on pace to have a
uh on pace to have a robust
personnel effort early on in the
administration because we know that
there are
so many places in the executive that
need
capacity and we are prioritizing the
same things that we prioritize in terms
of hiring for the transition which is
a diverse group of experts that know the
jobs that need to be done and are ready
to start leading on day one
and that are in many ways embodied not
in terms of specific people but embodied
as a group by the
type of people you saw in the agency
review teams folks who really understand
these agencies and are able to
effectively administer them once they're
given a chance
um our last question goes to jen epstein
um this is sort of
a piece of um what alexi asked uh
but you know are are you going to be
putting out rules around
ethics for the administration uh for the
white house staff
for um members of their president-elect
and vice president-elect's family
um soon uh and
and what what will those look like the
transition rules but
or will they be different um and
uh should we anticipate that we will see
the senior staff of the white house
being built out in the coming days
um or is that going to take longer
um since obviously i think we all a lot
of the reporters on this call
understand who a lot of those people are
but are waiting you know
to hear what their titles will be you're
eager for some personnel announcements
um so i will say that um you know as i
as i mentioned at the top of this call
um there was a little bit of time this
week in addition to getting national
security briefings and coveted briefings
and
announcing his advisory board um and
having
some public events for the
president-elect to spend some time with
post advisors
having discussions about personnel
obviously that's always a focus of any
transition
um as you saw yesterday was it yesterday
uh ron
claim the day before um ron kleiner was
announced as the chief of staff and he
and the president-elect are eager to um
you know get a senior's team and a
senior staff
finalized and certainly announced in the
coming weeks
because they they know they have a lot
of work to do i can't give you an
exact date or anything i can just
reiterate for you that it's a priority
and
we hope to have some updates on that for
you soon and on the ethics
piece um you know we have a robust
um ethics pledge that is signed by
anyone who's working on
the uh transition um and certainly
um as we get closer to announcements
about additional
about personnel for an administration i
would expect violent information on that
i don't know if johannes has anything to
add any parting thoughts wisdom for the
weekend
just appreciate everybody making time
and we'll be in touch
yeah thanks everyone for joining
thank you
you